uh let's do a little bit of a um
i don't know talking sense on
vaccination
because the vaccination disinformation
that is spreading
is absolutely ridiculous now i want to
be very clear
this is not a segment to correct medical
misinformation about vaccines
later today we'll talk to dr eric topel
about the medical aspects of vaccination
we've done that before uh so so this is
not about
oh the vaccine will give you covet or
bill gates will micro trip you
we've debunked that stuff separately
this is a segment about
the political misinformation about
coronavirus vaccines things like
trump delivered a vaccine or
operation warp speed is doing great
thanks to america for the vaccine that
type of stuff
so this is going to be a great
opportunity to go over where we are
today
on vaccination and the bottom line is
the first vaccine to be approved
the pfizer biontech vaccine was
developed by two turkish immigrants to
germany
in germany very early in the pandemic
before donald trump did
a thing about the coronavirus it had
nothing to do with trump
it had nothing to do with the trump
administration period donald trump has
bragged about how thanks to him
we developed vaccines faster than ever
before that has
nothing to do with donald trump the
reason we developed vaccines so quickly
is that the mrna platform for vaccines
instead of working on dead or weakened
virus
works by giving cells instructions for
how to make
proteins that trigger an immune response
that technology by its nature shortens
the vaccine development time
that's why the vaccines both in and out
of the us were developed so quickly
has nothing to do with donald trump uh
so so in terms of development there's
very little to even talk about regarding
donald trump
now what does have to do with donald
trump is vaccine distribution
in the united states and that's been an
absolute and total disaster
number one remember that donald trump
previously promised us 100 million
vaccine doses by the end of the year
last year 2020 we didn't get there
more recently the trump administration
promised 20 million
vaccinations by the end of 2020. we did
not get there
and where we are today and uh bloomberg
has a very good vaccine tracker
is that as of a few hours ago 13 million
doses of the vaccine have been
distributed and that term were still
unclear on on
distributed means what exactly only
4 million 4.3 million first doses have
been
injected and remember that you need two
doses
with the current vaccines the second
doses are just now
starting so we were supposedly going to
have 20 million vaccinated by december
31st
instead we have 4.3 million partially
vaccinated
by january 5th this is an abject failure
now it's not completely clear what the
hold up is
but this is going very much like testing
they lied about testing early
and they seem to be lying about vaccines
early as well
so for things that actually have to do
with trump which are
vaccination distribution it's a disaster
there is one other aspect to this
vaccination is going to remain
slower than it has to be thanks to
donald trump
as i told you last the week before last
in late july trump turned down the
opportunity to buy another 100 million
doses from pfizer
so pfizer said okay well if you don't
want them we'll sell them to other
countries and that's exactly what they
did
so instead of getting another 100
million doses in the first quarter of
this year
or even in the second quarter of this
year donald trump has now
salvaged a purchase of 100 million more
pfizer doses
from a future shipment which are due to
us by july
31. we don't get those until july 31
that means that those will not be
injected into people
until august september and october
utterly embarrassing and a total failure
that's the real record
of the trump administration on vaccines
great things have
happened including the development of
multiple effective vaccines
uh and and the start of a vaccination
program none of that has to do with
trump where trump was involved which is
this early logistics program
it's been a failure it would be
hilarious
except it is an utter tragedy of
cataclysmic proportions
which is leading to unnecessary death
hopefully
president joe biden will be able to
accelerate vaccine distribution
we'll have more about this on the david
pakman show
instagram page find us there at david
pakman show
you can find me on instagram as well at
david.pakman
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but
helix has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video